мехенді агабалян
зігмар габріель і 57 до зайвої віце
канцлер та міністр економіки енергетики
не митч він і переміг посаду міністра
закордонних праворуч вин заміни
франк-вальтер штайнмайєр ці 20 ти таку
лютого допомагаєте за крісло президента
чи над брекзит прямо хоч трампа
when i was very це конфлікту в Україні
вчили ось мзср ніж а лівий клік у
українському харчування сама учням
займе channel 1 злісних арбітри в
між сторонами конфлікту на Донбасі
вин жопе кується в зануренням мінському
кексів дайсо і зігмар габріель у кого
багатий аналітики називають нато лояльним
до кремля
ранку увагу guru coffee на wix
причиною по разу міні ведмедика і вам і
берліном, який заявив про пеніс навколо нього
газ косово не сантей з проти Росії та
запалити і наташа ку партія Петро і мало їх
не проводити габріеле заїхати словами
виступаючи за справу з москвою поважаючих
чудова тревал ізоляція нічого не дмц
діалог політик no lo que je на провідній
Москву повстанню Варіс йому на лузі руку
чи над бомбардами вами росію сирійського
Алеппо студії Габріель під самого вечора
завжди вид вигляду та блоками ну-ка видно
сон і заходу за росію за хвалиться
зігмар габріель був у Москві 80-м і
коли захир бику то вам олімпійські ігри